[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 l'actualité locale et
régionale en 26 minutes tout de suite
les titres de ce mardi 19 juin la
décision a été adoptée hier lors de deux
conseils municipaux en simultané le
chesnay et rocquencourt vont se
rassembler dans une commune nouvelle est
la fusion devrait être effective dès
l'an prochain avec l'élection d'un seul
et unique mère et nous étions enchaîné
hier soir reportage c'est le fruit d'une
concertation menée pendant près d'un an
là derrière s'est dotée d'un projet
éducatif local jusqu'en 2020 il définit
les orientations objectifs et moyens
éducatifs pour en parler en plateau
clément ortega est notre invité il est
le chef de cabinet du maire de la ville
enfin à deux jours de la fête de la
musique à notre portrait de la semaine
et en mélodies ce soir rencontre avec le
groupe local de john walker saint trio
blues qui se produira ce samedi à
guyancourt et dans cette édition nous
recevons également le docteur gildas
ducharne chirurgien du service
d'orthopédie à l'hôpital privé est de
trappes on parlera avec lui dans un
évènement organisé demain à destination
des professionnels de santé du secteur
elle était dans l'air depuis plusieurs
semaines la fusion entre le chesnay et
rocancourt a franchi une nouvelle étape
ce lundi soir en conseil municipal est
les deux villes ont voté la première
phase de ce rapprochement et notamment
le nom de la future commune nouvelle qui
sera le chesnay rocancourt les
précisions avec ce sujet de michael et
demi d'euros le chesnay rocancourt vont
bientôt former une seule et même commune
les deux conseils municipaux ont voté ce
lundi 18 juin le principe de faisabilité
d'une fusion cette nouvelle ville
regroupera sous le nom le chesnais
rocancourt trente deux mille habitants
début janvier 2019 avec un seul maire à
sa tête
nous nous avons travaillé depuis le mois
de septembre
régulièrement
pour apprécier le bien fondé de cette
nouvelle commune et quand nous avons
fait nos deux colonnes le pour et le
contre et bien avons vu qu'au mois de
mars le colonnes pour était quasiment
rempli dans la colonne des pour selon
les élus cette mesure permettra au
concours de bénéficier des structures et
des services de la ville du chesnay dans
le sens inverse les chesnaysiens
pourraient eux réaliser des économies en
réduisant notamment les indemnités sur
le manque de logements sociaux c'est
l'optimisation des dépenses qui est
importante même s'il y a effectivement
une dotation globale de fonctionnement
qui est bonifié et même si effectivement
sur l'arrêté de carence il y aura plutôt
des bons résultats et nous aurons aussi
également de bonnes actions d'urbanisme
dans ce sens aux chaînés la fusion
recueilli 30 et une voix pour et 2
contre l'opposition a critiqué le manque
de communication conseil municipal et
aurait préféré une autre orientation
stratégique pour la ville
considérons que la cette fusion arrive
bien tardivement
parce que la ville leur concours est
beaucoup trop petit désormais pour pour
fusionner avec le chesnay dans les
circonstances actuelles il faut
fusionner plus tôt avec une grande ville
en l'occurrence versailles pour arriver
une taille critique puissante pour poser
dans le grand paris prochaine étape la
présentation globale du projet le 8
octobre prochain le futur nom des
habitants n'est lui pas encore connue
pourrait être sommé une consultation sur
internet à s'élancer le site internet
didier pour faire sa demande de
remboursement du passe navigo et de la
carte imagine r a ouvert la sncf va
dédommager à hauteur de 50% les
utilisateurs du réseau transilien
impacté par la grève des cheminots pour
les mois d'avril et de mai cette mesure
ne concerne pas les lignes de métro de
bus le rer a à l'est de paris et le rer
b au sud des justificatifs de domicile
et de votre lieu de résidence de votre
lieu de travail par dons seront
nécessaires pour la procédure et vous
avez jusqu'au 22 juillet pour effectuer
cette demande de remboursement ce
document à présent fixe les grandes
orientations valeurs et objectifs pour
2020 jusqu'en 2020 en matière
d'éducation la verrière s'est dotée d'un
projet éducatif local alors pour en
parler avec moi en plateau clément
ortega bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur du cabinet du maire de la
verrière première question pourquoi se
doter de ce pel ce projet éducatif local
parce que on a fait le constat qu'on
faisait plein de choses nous ville plein
d'action éducative en direction des
jeunes des moins jeunes aussi
c'est à dire à partir de trois mois
jusqu'à 25 ans considère qu'on avait un
certain nombre de deux dispositifs de
d'actions mises en place et puis qui a
multitude de partenaires l'éducation
nationale en premier lieu et puis
d'autres comme la caf comme la
préfecture avec différents services la
direction de départementale de la
jeunesse et des sports
un certain nombre de deux partenaires
plein d'associations et que au final on
avait des dispositifs qui était
pertinent qui allait nous pensons dans
un objectif politique éducative plutôt
plutôt dans le bon sens
à un moment donné il a fallu que nous
fassions un diagnostic que nous
regardions ce que nous faisions les uns
et les autres et puis que nous essayons
de nous coordonner cette action soit
coordonnée alors concrètement dans ce
document qu'est ce qu'on découvre on
découvre différents objectifs généraux
aussi opérationnel de ce fait elle alors
oui il ya des des objectifs
le principal objectif des envies dire la
philosophie de ce texte c'est de dire
comment nous différents partenaires nous
pouvons aider les enfants donc les tout
petits 3 mois on commence notre notre
projet éducatif commence dès la petite
enfance jusqu'à 25 en 26 ans c'est à
dire l'accès à la l'autonomie des jeunes
eh bien l'on considère que toute cette
période là il faut permettre à tous et à
toutes de réussir mais la question se
pose c'est que c'est quoi la réussite
est donc nous nous avons déterminé que
la réussite
c'était pas forcément d'avoir une maison
une voiture un chien des enfants c'est
pas ça la réussite est d'ailleurs c'est
ce que nous ont dit dans la concertation
un certain nombre de jeunes disent mais
la réussite c'est quand on découvre
quand on apprend quand on accède à
l'autonomie entre autres par la question
de l'emploi c'est l'épanouissement
individuel et collectif
voilà c'est ça que nous avons voulu
porter pour montrer que dans une ville
comme la verrière ont réussi mais pour
que les jeunes puissent réussir il faut
s'en donner les moyens
vous avez parlé de la concertation elle
s'est déroulée sur plusieurs mois
comment s'est-elle déroulée avec qui et
auprès de qui s'est déroulée cette
concertation
alors elle s'est fait effectivement ça a
été long ça a été vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure
près d'un an vous dirais même quasiment
plus d'un an elle a été elle a été
lancée nous avons voulu rencontrer les
partenaires qui travaillait donc des
professionnels entre milieux l'éducation
nationale avec les enseignants mais
aussi les agents de la ville qui
participent à l'éducation
je pense aux atsem si on reste dans la
question de l'école mais je pense aussi
aux animateurs à l'ensemble des services
au service culture aussi et puis des
partenaires qui intervenait sur la
question de la parentalité ou sur la
petite enfance je pense entre autres à
la caf je pense aux services de la
préfecture
nous avons mis nous les avons nous avons
des entretiens individuels et puis il ya
eu des tables rondes
avec des élus et puis il ya eu aussi des
moments de débats et on a voulu aussi
faire participer bain les premiers
concernés c'est à dire les jeunes eux
mêmes
on sait qu'en matière d'enseignement
c'est bien sûr l'éducation nationale qui
a la main sur les programmes du coup sûr
quel domaine peut agir là la ville de la
dernière quels sont les moyens d'action
pour pour une ville alors j'ai juste
revenir sur la question de l'éducation
nationale parce que j'ai pas envie de
balayer d'un revers de main la
responsabilité de l'éducation nationale
elle est effectivement centrale elle est
déterminante dans ce dans ce projet là
ça veut dire surtout la première chose
c'est qu'il faut nous donner les moyens
il faut que l'éducation nationale se
donne les moyens de dans les écoles de
la verrière
nous avons obtenu que les classes nous
ne soit pas supérieure à 25 d'enfants
par classe c'est entre autres parce que
nous avons eu tout ce débat là et que
nous avons démontré que si on surcharge
les classes et ben c'est pénaliser
encore plus les enfants qui sont donc
nous avons voulu porter ça plus en amont
en sélection aussi sur le temps scolaire
à la verrière bien entendu oui sauf que
là aussi on se retrouve encore sur une
question de moyens nous allons supprimer
les nappes pour pour l'année prochaine
c'était une demande d'une partie du
corps enseignant une partie des parents
mais lorsqu'on a fait la consultation
on était à 49 51 % ce qui a fait
basculer le fait qu'on arrête les nappes
c'est que nous n'avons plus les moyens
parce que nos dotations diminué que nous
avons perdu un million d'euros en quatre
ans et que de fait on a un certain
nombre d'actions que matt nous nous
sommes obligés de transformer
c'est une des raisons entre de ceux de
ce pel c'est que à moyen même pas
constant à moyens diminuant et bien il
faut trouver
d'autres solutions pour permettre à ces
jeunes de ne pas être abandonnée de
pouvoir réussir et je de réussir mais
aussi que eux mêmes se construisent et
ses salles importantes dans ce sens dans
ce projet dont nous la ville
on y met les moyens on a mis en place on
avait des maisons de quartier nous avons
transformé en centre socioculturel ça
veut dire que nous avons réintroduit la
question de la culture de l'animation de
la parentalité au coeur des quartiers
voilà nous avons décidé de miser sur la
jeunesse
nelly d'études depuis qu'elle est élu
depuis deux ans elle dit l'admission la
première priorité de la ville c'est la
jeunesse
ce plan est une réalité pour consulter
pour les téléspectateurs qui souhaitent
consulter ce programme éducatif local
il est disponible sur le site internet
de la verrière qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci avec les morts tega jour
être avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes directeur du cabinet du maire
de la verrière passer du cm2 à la
sixième de l'école élémentaire ou au
collège un moment clé dans la scolarité
d'un jeune le week-end dernier à
elancourt a été récompensé six cents
élèves arrivés au terme de leur parcours
en primaire cérémonie organisée à la
salle du prisme ils ont reçu des mains
du maire jean michel fourgous un coffret
numérique un diplôme ainsi qu'un chapeau
comme dans les universités américaines
un propos recueillis par nicolas landry
l'objectif c'est de leur souhaiter bon
courage pour la continuité de leur
apprentissage scolaire au collège et et
de mettre un point d'orgue alors
scolarité sur elancourt en école
élémentaire et donc de fêter avec eux et
leur famille leur entrée au collège à
elancourt toujours deux classes ont été
récompensés ce mardi après-midi au
concours des villes marraines des forces
armées ses élèves de l'école nouvelle
amsterdam ont échangé avec la flottille
21f de la marine nationale jeunes et
marins se sont rencontrés en classe et
sur la base militaire de lann bihoué
près de lorient elancourt participe
depuis plus de dix ans à ce programme
qui permet de valoriser le lien entre
jeunes et unité militaire organisé par
l'association des villes marraines il
s'adresse aux écoles collèges et lycées
le président de l'association explique
en quoi consiste ce concours c'est au
micro de mélanie poké c'est un concours
national qu'organise l'association des
villes marraines des forces armées que
je préside qui rassemble 150 trois
villes en france qui comme l encours ont
le statut de ville marraine d'une des
unités des forces armées
qu'il s'agisse de la marine nationale de
l'armée de l'air de l'armée de terre ou
la gendarmerie nationale et là c'est un
concours concours caroline aigle
capitaine autissier qui sont deux femmes
aviateurs de l'armée de l'air pionnière
qui malheureusement sont décédés
prématurément et nous avons donné leur
nom à ce concours qui permet de
récompenser des classes des villes
marraines qui sont en relation avec
l'unité avec l'unité militaire dans la
ville est précisément la marraine on
accueille sur ce plateau un nouvel
invité le docteur gildas ducharme
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes chirurgien
orthopédique spécialisée dans les
membres inférieurs vous faites partie du
groupe d'orthopédie de l'hôpital privé
de l'ouest parisien cet attrape alors ce
groupe se nomme ortho ouest et vous
organisez et demain à la ferme du manet
à montigny le bretonneux un événement ça
sert à mettre à jour les connaissances
en orthopédie pour les professionnels de
santé certains professionnels de santé
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
juste après déjà quelques éléments de
définition quand on parle de chirurgie
orthopédique ça concerne quelle partie
du corps la chirurgie orthopédique
concerne toutes les parties du corps où
se trouvent des autres articulations des
muscles et des tendons tout ce qui
concerne l'appareil permet de marcher ou
de saisir ou de se tenir debout
ce qu'on appelle le new l'appareil
locomoteur vous faites partie du groupe
ortho est c'est très chirurgien qui
composent ce groupe au sein de l'hôpital
privé l'ouest parisien
exactement cette équipe est appelée à
grossir régulièrement tous les ans tous
les ans tous les deux ans nous
accueillons un nouveau collègue un
nouvel associé
le but de tout se fasse et d'avoir de
pouvoir offrir à nos patients une prise
en charge hyperspécialisés quittant
c'est le courant habituel en orthopédie
c'est à dire devenir presque mono
articulaires sur la prise en charge afin
d'offrir aux patients la meilleure prise
en charge possible si c'est d'être
j'imagine précurseur dans le domaine de
l'orthopédie
alors on est précurseur dans le sens où
on a réussi dans une structure privée à
se regrouper entre différents chirurgien
ce qui permet d'offrir à nos patients à
la parfois une même prise en charge
pluridisciplinaire des patients qui
nécessitent des prises en charge à la
fois sur la main sur la hanche ou bien
des interventions qui peuvent être
particulièrement l'autre qui nécessite
la prise en charge par de chirurgie en
simultané
un autre élément de définition important
c'est le champ d'action de l'hôpital
privé l'ouest parisien il s'étend sur
tout le sud yvelines mais mais au delà
aussi tout à fait nous ont des passions
qui viennent essentiellement du secteur
de vous que vous avez cités mais
également d'un secteur qui va jusqu'à
dreux jusqu à chartres et donc le pardon
pour parler toujours du groupe porto est
on peut parler aussi du service sos
mains qui est classé 1er en urgence
chirurgicale en ile de france ça peut
tout à fait nous ils ont traité l'an
dernier 5000 urgence main l
établissement c'est à dire corto reste
est composé des meilleurs chirurgiens en
la matière meilleur je ne sais pas
expérimenté ça c'est sûr demain donc
vous organisez un ep eu alors le pays ça
veut dire enseignements post
universitaire ça se passe à la ferme du
manet à montigny le bretonneux
l'objectif de
de cet événement c'est mettre à jour des
connaissances en orthopédie wii afin de
nous nos correspondants puisse savoir ne
soit pas totalement démuni lorsqu'il
voit arriver des patients présentant des
pathologies ostéo-articulaires qu'ils
puissent avoir les premiers réflexes qui
soient les bons nous également
d'organiser cet événement nous oblige à
mettre à jour nos propres connaissances
afin de leur offrir des données qui
soient les dernières mises à jour quoi
faut-il mettre à jour ses connaissances
elle évolué au fil des années ses
connaissances seulement résolu mais en
plus elles évoluent dans tous les
domaines de la de la médecine et comme
la médecine et trans peut-être
transdisciplinaire en ce qui concerne
les chirurgies orthopédiques puisque on
peut être amené à utiliser parfois des
antibiotiques ont fait référence à
certains centres de référence locaux
désinfection ostéo articulaires la mise
à jour de nos connaissances dans ce
domaine là que l'on peut retransmettre
en essayant de l'est c'est à dire les
vulgariser puisqu'on parle à des
collègues mais on est sur des simplifiée
pour permet d'avoir je pense une prise
en charge en tout cas bien meilleur pour
nos passions vous allez retransmettre
ses connaissances est mise à jour de
connaissance demain à plusieurs
professionnels de santé de qui s'agit-il
qui sera qui sera présent quels types de
professionnels seront présents des
médecins généralistes qui travaillent
sur le secteur des rhumatologues des
kinésithérapeutes et des infirmiers
infirmières alors l'événement a déjà
attiré plus de 300 personnes ça c'était
il ya deux ans demain vous attendez
combien de personnes nombreux similaires
en tout cas à ce jour 300 personnes dans
la foi on commence à se déroulera cet
événement ça se déroule avec cette année
on a un participent à ce qu'on appelle
la formation médicale continue au sens
institutionnel c'est à dire que cela va
valider pour les praticiens qui viennent
nous voir des points de formation
médicale continue
enfin des hors des heures de formation
médicale continue et on va d'abord
commencer le la présentation par un quiz
avec quelques questions assez simple
mais dont les réponses sont pas
forcément évidentes
puis faire plusieurs présentations c'est
assez didactique et enfin remettre à
jour les connaissances à partir de ce
quiz à la lumière de tout ce qu'on
expose exploser auparavant d'année
dernière question qu'attendez vous de
cet événement cac sont finalement les
objectifs ils sont multiples à la fois
connaître nos correspondants puisque
c'est vrai qu'ils ont déconné souvent
que par le courrier qui nous adresser
les patients qui nous annonce ensuite
que ne nous connaissent également ça va
dans les deux sens et puis ça permet de
faire ce genre de formations qui peuvent
parfois être un peu rédhibitoire de
faire dans une ambiance plutôt
sympathique merci à docteur gildas
ducharme d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous faites partie du
groupe porto ouest et ortho ouest
organise demain son événement annuel à
la ferme du manet à montigny le
bretonneux et ortho ouest vous pouvez
retrouver plus d'informations sur ce
groupe d'orthopédie de l'hôpital privé
de l'ouest parisien sur son site
internet
à qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran vous
l'avez suivi dans notre journal hier
plus de quinze mille lycéens yvelinois
plancher sur l'épreuve de philosophie
vendredi à guyancourt la philosophie se
jouait au rythme du rock'n roll rock'n
philo est née dans l'esprit d'un
professeur de philosophie qui est
musicien et après un ouvrage il a
décliné ce concept en concert mélanie
poker là aussi la démarche de voltaire
dans la douleur donald young est la même
dans la chanson de la viande
on fait le constat empirique du mal qui
existe voilà un mariage auquel on
n'aurait pas pensé
voltaire et neil young partagent le même
idée dans candide et rocking in the free
world
à la guitare francis métivier professeur
de philosophie amateurs de rock'n'roll
et créateur du rock'n philo ça remonte à
l'adolescence en fait j'ai découvert à
la fois le rock et la philosophie en
prenant conscience au fond que les deux
avaient des messages à des
questionnements et des messages à peu
près équivalent évidemment exprimé dans
des formes très très différentes mais il
ya un point commun qui est le côté un
peu contestataire la remise en cause de
l'ordre établi que ce soit chez socrate
en philosophie par exemple ou chez dylan
dans le domaine de la folk song après un
premier ouvrage du même nom en 2011
francis métivier prend sa guitare et
monte sur scène accompagné de christian
jeantet et philippe du janerand
[Musique]
ma gueule qui va me permet d'expliquer
la liberté chez sartre le regard de
l'autre qui me prive de ma liberté sans
questionnement qui intéresserait les
gens parce que c'est vraiment un thème
philosophique et erroc 1 les deux faces
est pas le seul un ignorer le désirent y
aurait l'amour y aurait plein l'histoire
il y aurait plein de choses les
spectateurs n'ont pas eu de copie à
rendre à l'issue de secours concert et
ont goûté à la liberté
[Musique]
à
la musique toujours avec notre portrait
de la semaine consacrée au groupe de
john walker sur le trio joue un blues
rock efficace qui vous emmène tout droit
au far west il jouera jeudi soir à
versailles async à mantes la jolie et
samedi à guyancourt camille lambert et
nicolas andrillon rencontrer le groupe
lors de l'enregistrement de son nouvel
album regarder
[Musique]
prouver que le rock et la country ne
sont pas réservées au groupe américain
c'est le pari de ce jeune trio yvelinois
1 sont accrocheurs et moderne où
résonnent des riffs dans la plus pure
tradition de 12 des influences variées
mais un style très personnel
j'écoute beaucoup de musique différente
j'ai commencé surtout par le rock et
leur drogue avec des groupes comme ac/dc
deep purple led zeppelin et après je
suis allé chercher laurent leur
inspiration pour comprendre le couche
parti vert blues puis après le l'ancien
blues le delta blues qui est plus plus
anciens quand on voit beaucoup de coups
pelouse mais qui chante en français et
qui font un espace de on va dire de deux
copies des américains et nous ce qu'on
essaie de faire c'est de prendre ses
influences là mais de faire quand même
notre propre son
[Musique]
un son reconnaissable grâce à la voix
grave et rocailleuse de fabien fondateur
du projet formé à la tech music school
de londres et au cfpm de paris il crée
the jam walker en 2013 et sort un
premier album plutôt acoustique
c'est à partir de 2017 et le pea le mode
free que le groupe prend une tournure
plus électrique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ayant commencé la guitare à 7 ans fabien
est aujourd'hui professeur et consacre
tout son temps à cet instrument sa
passion ils pensent ses compositions
pour emmener l'auditeur au coeur des
régions sudiste
c'est l'américain duchesne on va dire le
delta si ce type i tous à épier
nashville aussi avec la contribution
mans donc la guitare slide et comme à
s'équiper de la guitare qui joue
beaucoup aussi le fait de jouer sur un
guitar résonateur les premières guitares
amplifiées en fait il n'y avait pas
d'ampli électrique à l'époque et du coup
ils ont fait un système de caunes en
métal pour faire résonner le sont
beaucoup plus forts en fait
[Musique]
le groupe se retrouvent chaque semaine
pour répéter actuellement il enregistre
son deuxième album à la batterie de
guyancourt on garde toujours cette
essence de la mousserie en rajoutant des
morceaux dans cette veine là qu est ce
qu on a plus d'une dizaine de nouvelles
compos depuis l'année dernière
facile donc c'est le bon moment pour
pour les enregistrer qu'on sortie prévue
en 2019 pour découvrir sur scène delta
blues corrosif de jay walker zh
rendez vous à la fête de la musique un
jour de festivités à montigny le
bretonneux samedi dernier a eu lieu la
fête de la vie une édition à dominante
cette année une dominante historique les
visiteurs ont pu profiter d'attraction
et d'ateliers autour de la période
médiévale
ils ont pu faire notamment un tour dans
une grande roue en bois nicolas landry
et est ou qui nirhy lanto danses
saynètes en costumes d'époque grande
roue humaine tonalité médiévale pour la
fête de la ville à montigny le
bretonneux
pour cette fête d'antan les visiteurs
ont été accueillis à la ferme du manet
objectif pour la municipalité réunir les
générations autour d'un voyage dans le
temps autrefois n'avaient pas
d'électricité
donc là on va mettre à contribution les
parents pour que les enfants puissent
s'amuser sur les balançoires ou sur la
grande roue des attractions mais aussi
plusieurs ateliers
tout le monde a mis la main à la pâte
les jeunes ont pu notamment s'essayer à
la fabrication de blé
[Musique]
quant aux plus courageux ils ont eu le
droit aux initiation à l'équitation
pendant ce temps les plus grands
expérimenté le tir à l'arc ou revenait
sur les inventions de l'époque des
festivités qui semble avoir satisfait
les visiteurs suis venu avec mon petit
fils passé ça change de la fête des
voitures donc effectivement médiévale
oui c'est un nouveau thème à l'ancienne
donc c'est comment dire pour eux ces
histoires de voir un peu comment
et l avenir cette époque là ils n'auront
plus qu'à patienter jusqu'à l'année
prochaine pour une nouvelle fête de la
ville et puis nous sommes à tout juste
100 jours du début de la ryder cup à
saint quentin en yvelines elle se
déroulera à partir du 25 septembre au
golf national situé à guyancourt le site
qui pourrait recevoir donald trump le
président des états unis est annoncé
comme l'un des invités probable de la
compétition lui qui est un grand amateur
de golf selon la nbc il passerait un
quart de son temps à y jouer sa venue ou
non à saint quentin en yvelines ne sera
officialisée que dans les derniers jours
précédant l événement voilà c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi les
reportages et le replay sont à consulter
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 à suivre juste
après nouveau numéro du 7 8 et co
présentée par aurélie rose belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]